this is why on all my landing pages i
always ask for email first
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back what's up we're back
from miami and we got a new nickname i
am sean fury he is
the vanilla gorilla and we are back
uh we had to wing it this episode
because we had a guest cancelled last
minute
but i think it turned out pretty good so
sam what do we talk about yeah so this
episode actually turned out
i think to be one of my favorite in a
long time we
probably discussed maybe 20 or 30 ideas
um the ideas start about halfway through
but we have a bunch of interesting ideas
that are scattered throughout so a few
things that we've discussed so
businesses that we've
both invested in recently including an
event business we've talked about
slingshot ideas so slingshot ideas that
are
ideas that have been kind of under the
radar because of kovid but now that
there's a lot of pent-up demand for
events for interaction things like that
these are going to be slunk shot is that
the right word slung shot slung
shooted back into popularity we talked
about litigation finance so basically
there's a whole bunch of people that
will
finance lawsuits and then take a cut the
winning uh
winning uh settlement kind of
interesting we talked about secondhand
stores
shockingly that's actually it seems like
a huge idea and then finally we wrapped
up with one of the best sean stories
i've ever heard where we talked about
door-to-door sales
trust me it's going to leave you fired
up it's in the last 15 minutes it's
awesome
we were supposed to have bill smith from
hello landing on
i got an email from his pr team
literally 60 seconds before we were
supposed to hit record saying he's not
gonna make it i don't know what
what we're gonna do today i'm so angry
about that oh my gosh i'm frustrated
i gotta give you credit you uh you
replied back to the email to the pr
person the pr person
60 seconds before the podcast is
supposed to record right we're in like
the sound room
in a green room getting sound check and
uh it's like
hey folks uh sorry not gonna be able to
make it today looking forward to
rescheduling
and um it just goes are you kidding
one minute before the podcast
no context
and i thought that are you kidding was
uh very ballsy i would have just
i would have just ate it just took the
slap and uh
i think you rightfully you're rightfully
like what
i mean okay so i'm reading this book
called
non-violent communication i'm reading it
for
i'm reading it for two reasons the first
reason is i've gotten repeated feedback
from you
and abreu and my coworkers that i have a
temper i don't think i have a temper
so i'm trying to get that and my wife
sarah the second reason and this
feedback is pissing me off
i i yeah i i think i could be a little
hot and hey
you gotta say i was with you the whole
week we went to austin miami
and you were like an angel you were
totally patient
you were just being grateful the whole
time it was amazing and then you i think
you even noticed at the end i was going
to tell you
and then you go i've been i've been
really kind this whole trip i'm feeling
really kind and grateful
so i guess we can um we can talk about
that but uh
yeah so bill smith sorry brother like i
have
a feeling i have a feeling it wasn't
bill's fault
that that's what i would bet i bet he's
got people and i bet that he screwed
that up uh
they screwed it up not him but i uh i
replied
you know what happens like sometimes you
you don't sort of
you don't really think about the other
side you're just going about your day
one thing is rolling over
this other thing comes up and you're
just like uh we got to move that call
thing
we got to move that podcast thing and um
and so you know i've i've been on that
side where you know
i don't sort of fully you know
appreciate that the other
side of it has you know there's a lot of
prep that goes into a podcast like
multiple people on board and
timing and then you need to record
because you have to release and then
you're preparing for him you're
researching him you're not researching
other topics so then you got to go live
without them but
look we're not big shots yet i would
love to be a big shot
we're not big shots yet but i would say
we are big enough shots
that like someone like it would be wise
to take this at least seriously
and give like a little bit of a heads up
i'm not saying that we're like big deals
but like it's a good it's a good enough
platform
he wouldn't have rescheduled tim ferriss
a minute before the pot is that what
you're saying
oh definitely not look i'm not saying
that we're big deals
but i am and we are um all right now
let's just roll so i hope you come back
so
i don't know what we're gonna talk about
but you wanna do a recap of this weekend
uh yeah let's do it so we had a fun week
we went to i went to austin which is
your hometown stayed at your house
not my hometown my where your current
town yeah
and we did a live show uh i don't know
about 100 people
were able to fit into the venue we did
it at the appsumo office with noah kagan
that was fun then we hopped on a plane
next morning 5am
and uh got to miami where the bitcoin
conference was happening so there was
like 10 to 20
000 people in town for you know this
bitcoin thing
and we were there for our miami show and
i think i don't know a few hundred
people
i don't know how many ended up being
maybe i don't know what do you think dan
250 300 people something like that
well 300 people rsvp'd but i think or no
sorry
show up yeah something like that yeah so
200 people showed up or so
did the live show there met a bunch of
cool people people who flew in from
paraguay and
you know all different types of places
to attend and
um yeah then we hung out and we flew
home so that was a that's what happened
but there were some interesting things
that were going on give me your kind of
like
what do you think would be the most
interesting one or two things to talk
about from the trip i have a so
uh i have a bunch and and thank you bill
smith so i'm just rattling this off the
top of the dome there's no research here
but um the airports and hotel situation
in both miami and in austin
bananas absolutely crazy we went to the
airport i think we got there at about 6
a.m we left my house at 5 30 i think
and it was like an hour long wait
including
tsa pre-check to get past security and
it was booming i went to miami the
reason i came home early is because my
hotels
i went to book on hotel tonight and they
all got canceled for some reason
and i couldn't find a single hotel in
between the ranges of 200
and 2 000 in miami i had to go stay at a
family
uh family's house travel is
crushing it right now i'm i'm just
shocked at how booming
everything is yeah and also i came from
california
and um in california there's just like
covered
you know precaution everywhere and as
soon as we got to austin you were like
oh yeah this is my favorite like you
know coffee shop slash bar i don't even
know what the place was
a lazarus or whatever it is whatever
it's called and we walk in and
i was like it's like stepping into a
time machine
i was like whoa everybody's just
chilling everybody's hanging out at a
restaurant
indoors no masks uh ever some people had
their mask on that's cool that's their
choice and other people didn't
um but it just it was like wow life has
really gone on and people are back to
normal and
because in florida and texas i think
they're probably two of the most
like kind of forward states as far as
like returning to the norm
and then you know california i come back
and it's sort of the same thing you know
you
if your nose peeks out of your mask you
get three dirty looks
and uh i'm i'm over the mask mask time
i'm like i'm vaccinated
let's uh let's roll here yeah so that
was a takeaway
um with some covet stuff my thing where
do you think that do you see any
opportunities right now
so like you had heard about pent up
demand and how the economy is going to
bounce back
after seeing miami after seeing um
austin airport
um i've seen a little bit of new york
it's just it's booming
where do you think the opportunities are
do you have anything off the top of your
head that you're looking at
uh i'm glad i bought airbnb stock when
it was down because
i think everybody's going to do very
well because i do think people are
pretty
roaring to get back out there and doing
things traveling
traveling especially i know a lot of
people that haven't seen their family in
like
you know a year and a half type of thing
so i think that people are going to be
be coming back out that's not that like
you know insightful of an answer it's
just sort of
obvious um and i think that a lot of
things that we
we did as a necessary evil um
are gonna go away people are gonna ditch
those with quickness the same way i was
ready to just ditch my mask as soon as
it was okay to do it um i think you know
all the remote
learning stuff is gonna go away um
pretty quickly because people if it
wasn't a better experience
it's like going to the graveyard as soon
as you don't have to do it
and uh i think remote school is one
where
every parent every kid i've ever talked
to they had to do remote like you know
zoom school
they are not like oh you know i really
really enjoy
you know school from home like there's
people who enjoy work from home i don't
know anybody that enjoys school from
home so i think that's that side is like
gonna take a big hit
did you see this company so i'm going to
talk about a startup real quick
um that i just invested in i bet you
looked at it as well it was called mary
have you heard of mary it's be
married.com
no tell me about it uh so ankur so
basically i'm friends with
uh this guy named ankur who's a
successful entrepreneur
and he invests in stuff and he just
sends me interesting stuff i thought you
were on that list because
you maybe i just missed it or i think i
have a feeling you missed it and so
there's this co so i'm basically i'm on
the lookout
for companies that are uh going to be
take taking advantage
we have to come up with a cute name for
this like pent-up demand because it's
like
what are people going to care about
right now so jason calacanis had a good
phrase where he goes
slingshot startups they had a setback
they were pulled back during covid but
it like
it's like a slingshot when you when you
when you pull it back it's yes it's gone
backwards but it's building up this
momentum to
slingshot forward and i thought i liked
that that was a good little slingshot
startup so i'm looking at like
event event related stuff um
i think sex related stuff is going to be
quite interesting
what does that mean uh what are those
two examples
i invested in one company called fitness
ai and this was like a
app you use when you go to the gym so
it's like a trainer when you're at the
gym it would be like hey
cool like it knows your progression so
it basically say
it tracks all your reps so it knows what
weight you need to do next to get the
next
to get the maximum gains over like a few
month period of time
now when covet hit jim's clothes his
whole app became like
useless overnight and so he had to
re-architect the whole app to do at
in-home fitness but the reason i would
say is it's not that this startup
necessarily benefited from it
but you got to see what different
startups are made of when you saw the
entrepreneurs
you know pivot the plane mid-flight and
find a new path and actually start
growing at a time where they should have
been having a setback
another example is there's these guys
who keep emailing me
um guru hotel they were a yc startup
and they were you know software for
hotels to increase their bookings
and focus in latin america and of course
you know covert hits nobody's booking
hotels their business should really
struggle
and like they just made all these tweaks
and all these adjustments so that they
first stayed flat and then actually
started to grow um at a time when
their business should have cratered and
many lesser less determined
entrepreneurs
less adaptable entrepreneurs would have
uh would have gone under
and so i think it was a great the great
filter it weeded out
the entrepreneurs and you got to see the
entrepreneurs who actually succeeded
despite the circumstances
and those are the ones i think worth
betting on what's guru hotel about
i don't know exactly what they do they
basically i think what it is is it's
like
shopify for a hotel so most hotel
websites suck
so what they did was they just make they
make your hotel's website
higher converting and higher upselling
and so you're going to get an
incremental 10 to 15
in revenue because instead of paying
some you know your nephew to build a
wordpress
website for your your your hotel and it
hasn't changed
in eight years and you you know you
don't even touch it because you don't
know how to code it
um they basically take over the front
end website for your hotel
and in doing so they generate more
revenue for you and then they take a cut
or they take it
that sounds pretty great to me um have
you heard of mind body you know mind
body
yeah so mind body um they're publicly
traded
they were started in 2000 so they've
been around for a minute
and basically they kind of started out
doing that a little bit
just helping a a yoga instructor i think
it's mostly like it's health stuff
yeah so it's basically like yoga studios
pilates studios stuff like that and they
became the website
and the booking system and payment
system for all those
um physical uh like locations
yeah crazy good company um kind of
quietly i think they're based out of san
luis obispo so they're not silicon
valley
and so they've probably been quietly
crushing it uh
and what's this called hotel guru guru
hotel
yeah oh they should call the other yeah
they shouldn't they should switch it
it should be hotel gurus uh they should
switch
it's like so obvious when you said it i
hadn't even thought about it yeah they
they
they need to change that guru hotel oh
no
never mind rescind all five compliments
they uh well like i think there's a mind
body component here of like you just
create the first thing
and then next next next xxx next so i uh
are you gonna invest in that company uh
maybe like they keep sending me updates
and it all sounds good
but i just have this inherent thing that
the best startups don't reach out
randomly to
non-super famous investors like me so
unfortunately and this is like this is
kind of a screwed up thing
if a startup is reaching out to me to
try to make room i already discount 20
that doesn't mean i don't do it but i
discount 20 how good it is even when it
looks good so
yeah i know i'm in anybody else i'm the
same way i'm like oh you
you're willing to like it's like that's
what i felt like when i was dating like
oh you like me
uh something something's bad here right
this is crazy
um so there's there's this company
called mary i just invested in like i
said we send it to you
and i'm not sure if this is gonna be the
biggest thing but i think it could
definitely be a very profitable
investment it's called uh
mary m-e-r-r-o-i did you go to it it
looks like a first planet
be married.com um i'll tell you why i'm
interested but i'll tell you first what
it does so what it does is
you need to organize an event they've
uploaded i don't know how maybe there's
a huge database
uh out there but they've uploaded
massive amounts of
uh renderings or like floor plans of
event space and then they make it really
easy to drag and drop
different tables and chairs and whatever
you need for a wedding or a conference
and you can outline what the event is
going to look like and you do it in 3d
because somehow the floor blue it looks
like it looks like the sims
so it's like you take it you have the
venue and then it lets you upload like
circle table chairs banquet chairs you
know like speaker
like uh podium or whatever right it
looks like the sims you make a little
3d rendering exactly and the reason i
invested in this was
because of something that andrew
wilkinson said on this podcast
he called something an airport business
i think he called
uh what's that thing he owns dribble
yeah
he owns this thing called dribble and
where dribble is is uh or
i think he was referring to dribble when
he was we're talking about airport
business but basically
with dr uh with with an airport you
arrive at the airport
and you're there you have to be there
for three to four hours
uh you're gonna buy whatever they have
you're gonna if you're there it's very
easy for that airport to sell you candy
a magazine
you're a captive audience yes you're a
captive audience and
what mary did is they made it where they
uploaded all of these venues
and so people who are executing weddings
can go on there
and pay a fee to use their software to
drag and drop and like organize stuff
and then what they've done is so the
vendor can come on and put their
the stuff that they want to sell so like
certain types of chairs whether it's for
rent or to buy
it could be on there and then as the um
event planner is on there doing their
thing that they can sell
just the event planner loads and loads
and loads of different stuff so they can
make money through affiliate they can
make money through subscription fees
they can make money through a lot of
different stuff that they're on there
and the reason why i invested in this is
i think that this is a
boring boring thing that could work
quite well
and uh there's gonna be a massive
pent-up demand for events and so we put
a little bit of money into it
we'll see if it works but i love the
business of houzz you know house
h-o-u-z-z
i've i've heard of it and i think you
used that or something like that for
your
your house right no i use something like
that yeah so i use
what houses you probably don't know
houses probably the audience is probably
majority women
it's a uh you basically can design your
kitchen
or your bedroom on houzz and they make
like a billion dollars a year through
affiliate feeds
it's quite amazing and it's a it's a
multi-billion dollar company
but it's kind of been quiet in the
background it's kind of amazing what i
used was uh
what the [__] did i use uh i use this
service where you take a picture of your
house
mods yeah i took a picture uh this thing
where you take a picture of your house
and then they uh you pay 300
per room so i think i paid like 1200
bucks a designer designs it
and then if i choose to i can purchase
all these stuff that they're
telling me to buy or i just go buy stuff
on my own that kind of looks like it
right
by the way i like these models where i
don't know about you but for me whenever
it's like
hey you get the free consultation and
ideas and then it's up to you if you buy
them and at the beginning i'm always
like
sweet let me get the free expert advice
and like i'm not gonna buy the
things that's how i go in and then as
soon as i see it i'm like oh
that looks really good like i guess i
could just push this button and just
order these items right like i could
just buy these things and so it ends up
being
where they i go in knowing eyes wide
open on the model like it's like nerd
wallet it's like
cool i go in i read the blog post about
the credit cards i'm not gonna like just
pick one of these credit cards right off
here necessarily because i kind of know
you know there's like an affiliate thing
but uh but then i do because it's so
convenient and there's something to that
when i was selling my house
it was the same thing with staging
they're like cool like we're going to
we're going to do all this work to give
you these three free options on which
one you want to do
and then as soon as you see it you're
like ah okay
give me the give me the expensive one
i'll do it it looks so much better um
and so
you know it sort of breaks you over time
like a like the puppy clothes
where they give you the puppy they let
you keep it for the weekend and you're
like great i'll just play with this
puppy for the weekend and then by by
sunday night you're like this puppy's
never leaving my house
i didn't know that was a thing um you
never heard that in sales no puppy
clothes
basically you give them the thing and
then instead of having them opt-in you
have them
if okay you can opt out if you want and
nobody ever opts out
do you uh what are what are some other
slingshot startups that you're
seeing um or or slingshot opportunities
so the slingshot so it has to be
something that was set back
during covid so what was set back during
covet i think
phys physical anything physical retail
schools
travel hospitality like we just said um
there's other things that are like you
know like concerts and stuff like that i
think those are
i think those sports games concerts i
think those are all gonna
come back so i'll give you one which is
um sports games so
the nba playoffs is going on right now
and um i always wondered would people
have kind of like ptsd from kovad where
they don't want to be
even when it's safe they just don't want
to be close to other people without you
know in
confined areas um but these aren't sold
out
you know as many people as they'll let
in it's packed people are going nuts
uh they're having a good time and you
know it just feels good to be back in a
high
energy place again with a whole bunch of
other screaming you know lunatics
and so but i think what happened is i
think that
it's sort of like the nba franchise or
the the league
had to get pretty had to get like double
resilient because
all of a sudden this thing it just took
for granted which is all this ticket
revenue
went away for like a year and so now
they open their mind up to well what
other revenue stream should we have
should we allow sports betting should we
like should we do that should we sponsor
things that we weren't
sponsoring before should we do nfts oh
okay cool you know nba top shot we'll do
nfts as a source of revenue
so i think it's pretty interesting that
i think all these like pro sports are
going to bounce back
because they were already a premium
in-person experience
and now they were kind of lazy before
at innovating they didn't have to
innovate and covet made them innovate
the fan experience and the like business
model and i think
you know we should see some some good
things come from that last night
so did you watch the logan paul floyd
mayweather fight
i watched a little bit of it yeah a
little bit really i was in a warehouse
where we didn't have uh
streaming internet very strong and so i
you know it was choppy but i got to see
the last two rounds only
so it was it was like it was exciting so
basically if you were gonna go
i was gonna go but then i realized i
didn't two things happened one
someone gave me tickets and then right
before i was about to go get the tickets
they were like also like are you gonna
mention us in the hustle and i was like
no not a chance uh i thought this was a
gift
thank you but no thank you i didn't know
there were strings attached i'm out so i
gave up the tickets and also i didn't
like miami so i came home early
right it wasn't for me uh not for me at
all
i i i can see why some people like it it
ain't for me
um so last night basically logan paul
is a six foot two probably he weighed in
at 190 probably
fought at 2010 210 205 huge guy
and he fought floyd mayweather who's 44.
backspa
best boxer of all time but 44 and 160
pounds at his heaviest
right and i thought for sure floyd was
going to win
um and ended up being basically a draw
because they don't declare a winner
because it's an exhibition
but floyd did not do well and logan did
as good as he possibly could have which
is he didn't get knocked out
and from what i understand floyd did the
floyd thing where he just didn't do
anything he just played defense
he just let the clock run out he didn't
did he was it that he was unsuccessful
on offense or he just didn't try any
offense because he didn't need to
because he got paid either way
i think he's old well i think that he i
think age
it was a factor here and i think that he
uh sides the factor here
um i think that the reason why everyone
says floyd lost because a loss or floyd
is not winning and not knocking him out
everyone including me
thought for sure logan's gonna get
knocked out he didn't he did great he's
a winner the guy
like went from vining to fighting floyd
in a stadium
total winner but what he did before the
show was logan is known for like
collecting pokemon cards
and there's this whole trend if you
don't know about this on
of unwrapping cards and so i actually
love watching unwrapping
nba cards i don't even like the nba but
the title will be like
unboxing a michael jordan card i think
it's awesome i love doing it i love
watching this logan has this whole thing
where he does it
and he in his he created a necklace
that was basically the most expensive or
most rare pokemon card of all time
and he like put it in some type of like
safety thing and he
wore it around his neck as he was
walking out and what i think is gonna
happen
it was what i would what looked like
what he's setting up is that he is um
gonna sell that and i think that what
his brother did
jake paul was they during the knockout
when he when his brother fought a few
weeks ago
they had an nft right after the fight
right and i think that them
selling the memorabilia right away after
the fight
is a brilliant idea and that started a
little bit with nfts and but i think
that that idea is here to stay
uh that's interesting yeah so so just
for the context so he basically had
like the way that most uh fighters come
out they come out with their gold chain
their you know they come out with
diamonds on and he basically had a sort
of diamond chain
but the pendant was a charizard a one
million dollar
charizard card that was laminated as a
holographic charizard rare
uh blah blah blah and uh he's like i'm
wearing a million dollars on my chest
right now and it just helps because he's
already
invested in pokemon so him giving it
that
sign and giving it that credibility
using the platform made his own
collection worth more and made that
individual one worth more because it now
has the story of
this is the one that you saw on tv uh
not just the fact that it's a rare
charizard court so smart
smart move all around um these guys know
how to make money floyd had his mask
sponsored
he he had uh he had like everything
sponsored on his page
mask was sponsored by
ethereumsomething.org
like did you see that yeah i don't know
what it was it was it was crazy so
his hat his mask everything was
sponsored as he walked out because these
guys this was a
an all-time money grab it was great so i
want to tell you a cool
nft thing most nft things by the way
not that cool you you you have to
explain what
we're adding so many listeners sean that
you have to actually say what ft is
because i think
like a lot of people don't understand
i've got i've got an aunt and
a mother-in-law listening you gotta
explain what an nft is all right nft
is a piece of art that is uh digital
that's the way that most people are
using it today
it stands for this thing from crypto so
you've heard of bitcoin you might have
heard of ethereum
ethereum lets you create this thing
called an nft an nft just means
it's a unique uh a unique thing
so for example if i have a 100 bill and
sam has 100 bill we could swap it
and we would just know they're all the
same 100 bills the same as the other
but if i have a piece of art on my wall
sam has a piece of art on his wall we
can't just swap it
because my art is unique and his art is
unique and they're not going to be worth
the same amount
um even if we had you know sort of the
same pair of
of jordans you know they might be in
different condition or different years
whatever it is
so an nft is more like a pair of
fancy you know basketball shoes it's
what something that collectors will will
own
it can be used in many other ways but
the majority is that people are using to
collect
sort of to create and collect digital
art
they got popular because um a whole
bunch of people who were
what i call crypto rich right they made
their money on bitcoin they made their
money on ethereum they got tons of money
from that
and when nfts came out they were using
they were using their their winnings
to buy nfts and so they were buying nfts
for literally
millions and millions of dollars so you
uh and it blew people's minds it's like
wait that's just an image on a computer
screen why are you buying it for
millions of dollars and they would say
you know what's the mona lisa but some
uh you know but some paint on
a piece of paper right art has
art its value is in the meaning that
people give it so
anyways nft's got popular they've had
sort of a crash since
since the hype cycle because everybody
everybody poured in thought there was a
chance to make money
and then uh you know it's down the nft
market's down like 80 plus percent right
now
from where it was just a few months ago
so it's been very up and down
but i'll tell you something cool um that
the people who are not
there's a group with any technology
there's a hype cycle where people jump
in
just to try to make a buck and then
there's like the people who just
believed in it the whole time and when
the crash happens
they stay they don't go away and so i'll
tell you a cool
nft example so do you know who lamelo
ball is
a basketball player from the ball family
and they're kind of like a little
obnoxious
like the kardashians of like nba so go
to
lamelloball.i so
i met this guy or you know actually i
haven't met him yet ben met him
uh because we thought this project
sounded really awesome so
he partnered up with lamela ball and
lamella ball created his own nft
now here's how it works the website
looks awesome
yeah yeah exactly very good website so
um
there's there's like four different
types it's like he turned lamella ball
essentially into a pokemon card okay so
he you can collect these different
labellable types of of cards
now what do they do well the twist here
the reason i think it's kind of cool is
that this is called a dynamic nft
meaning
it uh most nfts when you make it it is
what it is the image or the video
is what it is it stays that way until
the end of time a dynamic one will
update or upgrade based on things that
happen so what this is is it's sort of
like a bet on the player so you can buy
one of these you can buy the
mvp card and today it's worth
not so much because he's never won an
mvp but if in his career he ever wins an
mvp the card will like um
like evolve like a pokemon card it'll
upgrade uh because it has been unlocked
because the thing actually happened
in real life so it's like today you're
betting these cheap options
will lamella ball ever win the nft will
he ever win
mvp will he ever win rookie of the year
will he win a championship
and if he does your asset that you
bought will dynamically upgrade
because it takes in the data from from
the real world that hey this event has
happened
and it is now worth more and it could do
more and specifically just to like kind
of round it out
but the price isn't it's not worth more
necessarily right
well and you know it's like most things
right like if uh if i
buy a michael jordan rookie card and
then michael jordan becomes the greatest
player of all time
that rookie card's worth more than it
was when he was a rookie and nobody knew
how good he would be
how do they literally so what i'm
looking at here uh is basically this
3d rotating image of the melody
trophy almost how are they making i mean
this looks awesome like the resolution's
amazing everything about like the way it
looks is
cool how are they making that i think
it's just 3d animators on the internet
they get them to make some custom stuff
for them and by the way
those that's a group of people who've
had a renaissance right now because
there's a whole bunch of famous people
that want their own nft
and to do that you need a digital artist
to make you your cool thing
so anyways one cool thing about this by
the way you buy the thing
and it comes with access so like let me
just read off the perks if you bought
like
the most expensive one so so the gold
the gold
lamella one is the rookie of the year
one it is guaranteed to evolve if he
wins rookie of the year which by the way
he will this year it comes with a it
comes with a physical card it comes with
750 and guaranteed endorsement deal
rewards so basically his endorsers
have to give you free stuff which is
kind of cool
um it comes with some official
merchandise from him you can you have a
chance to win nba game tickets valued up
to five thousand dollars
you have a 50 chance to receive
autograph memorabilia and you're going
to get exclusive access to video calls
that he's going to do with holders
of his his collectible so it's kind of
cool right what if a basketball card
came with access to the player right
like you know you buy the lebron card
and lebron
for all the holders of the of the
platinum card he's going to do a skype
call with them or
why the hell did i say skype a zoom call
with them you know once a year or
something like that
or you get you know a pair of game worn
shoes
you have a 10 chance of getting those or
something like that this is great
i think this is so cool what i want to
ask well i'll ask that in a second but
uh this is awesome i think like i'm not
that's like the guy who made this i
think he's like 20 21 years old he's
like
a steve bartlett type of i'm seeing
shades of steve bartlett again
in this guy who who's a hustler who made
this happen so that's actually what i
want to ask about
i wasn't going to skip ahead but i i do
we'll come back to this so
what i'm seeing on this website is that
this is basically this
lamello thing is basically a creation of
a company
called ethercards is that right uh yeah
maybe that's the name of his company
yeah
yeah his company is called ethercards
i'm looking at the traffic
if you go to similar web and look at the
traffic basically nothing
nothing nothing and then in one month
three million visitors all the traffic
is direct
meaning someone very likely is there's
just three million people in the very
first month of this thing being
launched in march typing in ether dot
cards
uh those numbers if you don't know
anything about these numbers that's a
really
that's phenomenal what i want to know
is how are people discovering these
types of things
so beautiful question i should have said
this at the beginning the change here is
not oh we went from a a
basketball card that's a piece of
cardboard that you buy
from target um to now a digital thing
that you have on on your
on your phone or on your computer it's
not just that
lamello owns his own ip he is releasing
his own card set
so otherwise the nba signs an agreement
with panini they're the guys who make
the
the all the the basketball cards or tops
right these these brands that make cards
and the players don't get directly
ascent from their
their own cards popularity so right now
like luka doncic he has the most popular
panini cards
and they're going up they're being sold
on the secondary market for thousands
and thousands of dollars
you know like a lebron card will sell
for for two hundred thousand dollars
but lebron doesn't get a cut of that
transaction
because he didn't issue it he you know
he as a collective group they signed the
rights you know
when they become an nba player the nba
cuts a deal and so they're gonna
sure they get some like shared royalty
stream of like you know whatever the
licensing agreement was nba wide but the
individual player doesn't get anything
and therefore also has no incentive to
promote this thing
whereas with this lamelo has minted his
own card he owns
whatever percent he negotiated with
ether cards
and lamella is going to be putting this
in his instagram story all the time and
he guess what he's got millions of
followers on instagram who
love lamella ball and so he's going to
get more value out of this than he would
ever get out of a traditional basketball
basketball card walk me through how this
young guy made ether cards and
in this business so basically ethercards
he just you know he made the website
it's
it's very slick very cool how is the
the tracking of of all these cards
possible
the the back-end technology of like
tracking the payment and all that
do they actually make it make that are
they building on top of something else
i don't know i think they're probably
building on top of something else that's
one of the best parts of crypto
is that because crypto is open source
crypto is about building protocols
um you can use those protocols to do
anything so we had fur con on here
uh i don't know did he talk about pac
protocol um
i don't know if you remember he's
building furkan's building something
called the pack protocol
out of his uh thing uh nft
yeah and basically it's just a protocol
where you or i can go on there and say
hey
you know just like you said you love to
watch people doing pack breaks of nba
cards
we could make our own mfm packs just
like jack butcher i think did with
visualize value
we could say great we want we want to uh
we're going to offer these
10 possible cards right inside one of
them gives you like an hour of business
coaching
another gives you a shout out on the
podcast another gives you a free shirt
another gives you just a twitter follow
whatever we come up with our rewards
we just type them in and it basically
says assign the probability to each
it's like oh you know the follow is high
probability and a hour of business
coaching is only one percent of people
should get this when they open a pack
we set the price and it'll basically
spin up like shopify for nfts it'll spin
up a website
where we can sell our packs and fans can
come they could buy them
and they can open them up and they can
have a chance of winning x inside we
didn't have to do any coding to make
that happen because
they have built the pac protocol into it
to make this happen and it's all saved
on the ethereum blockchain uh like it's
all the ownership is there
and so and they just take a cut of every
buy um
in exchange for having built this
technology for us so and back
and back to the ether cards so so so
these kids like built just the front end
and used someone else's protocol and
then they hollered at they somehow
got in touch with lamello i mean like
hey do you agree by the way
sorry just to catch up one second they i
don't know how we got touched the
lumbello i'm going to ask him but
uh after launching this project uh so
this thing did
hundreds of thousands of dollars in the
first day when it dropped um so
you know just the lamellae thing or the
thing did
did uh uh i don't know if i could say
the exact number but
north of three hundred thousand dollars
in during the drop
um and then uh other players by the way
it's so funny
saying like north of 300 like yeah
it did over 300 433 thousand dollars
like that's
like you know you got to give people the
information without giving people these
i'll give you a hint it rides with
700 000 like that's like what you're
saying
yeah basically so uh other nba players
including one of the most popular
players on the planet hit him up and was
like hey
saw the lamellae thing let's like talk
to my people let's do it
let's do my own and did this kid have a
following already on twitter or what
platforms are using
so he uh i'm gonna chat with him this
week but ben talked to him
while we were in miami and uh and what
he said was that he
got big his his claim to fame before
this was helping artists go viral on
tick tock
so he partnered with a bunch of
musicians he's like yo you know a bunch
of the viral things you've seen on tick
tock
i kind of architected those behind the
scenes i don't know what that means but
i'm like oh you got hustler dripping off
you like this is good
and did you how did ben so ben if you're
listening is uh
sean's co-worker basically they scheme
together how did ben find this
bet we saw the announcement on the espn
announced lamela ball is doing his own
nft we saw an article
i go i read the dynamic nft part how it
updates based on the player's actual
achievements in the real world and i go
i just best event i go this is [__]
genius find the genius who made this
and he went and he found the guy who
made it he scheduled a call i couldn't
make that call ben
ben did the call and uh ben gave me the
lowdown on like who this guy is he's
like he's awesome you should talk to him
and ben met him on social media yeah
just dm
ben has my i don't know if you use his
twitter or he has access to my twitter
where you can just dm anybody from my
account
and uh because my account has more
followers i get a higher rate of reply
so let's do there's so many takeaways
here for a listener i want to actually
want to go through these takeaways the
first is like
i'm actually amazed at this the way that
you found this was
not special correct maybe if ben used so
ben doesn't have a big following right
he's just no it looks normal
bmw ben levy or ben emily
i don't know his twitter something like
that ben and levy so yours looks special
you have 144 000 people
um most people would reply to someone
they have 144 000 people
but ben does it all he did was dm'd him
does the kid even know does he know who
you are like does he know
sean is like a popular podcaster or
anything no idea
okay great so that's the takeaway here
is that like you found
an opportunity by seeing it on espn you
had ben but you didn't have to have ben
no i i've done this myself that's how i
found ben by the way same thing
that's a huge takeaway here the other
takeaway is just that the setup tea
thing is cool
yeah yeah yeah exactly and i think
you're going to see more of this you're
going to see
famous people launching their own
limited edition
nfts that come with access to the person
and they own the whole thing so they're
not using they don't have to sign with a
label or
sign with uh or like rely on tops to go
make their card for them
they're gonna release their own cards
and they're gonna own their own upside
which is
obviously a much better thing for the
talent yeah this is amazing i love this
i have a couple other topics if you want
to go go go go
um okay let's do let's do two things
how do you how do so normally when we
when we research we have a document
what are you using reminds us on my
notes on my my my it's from my phone's
notes because i was just typing it while
we were like
we'd be out we'd meet somebody like for
example at the event where we did the
podcast some guy came up he's like hey
i'm a lawyer
i um i've been a lawyer in dallas for a
long time i drove down for the event
drove from dallas to austin
and uh you know i just love you guys
always get the wheels turning in fact i
can't just like be a normal lawyer
anymore i really want to do more
and he has this idea for litigation
finance he goes you know what that means
did you talk to this guy
no but can i guess what that means yeah
please basically
uh i think this is what peter thiel did
uh so is it win
okay so basically peter thiel is this
billionaire guy
who had a vendetta against gawker
because gawker outed him as being gay so
peter kill is a
powerful vc he's gay he didn't want
anyone to know he's gay gawker wrote an
article saying he's gay
and so he plotted for 10 15 years
probably 10 years he goes whenever i see
these guys slip
i'm pouncing so 10 years later after
this article
hulk hogan uh has a sex tape issue and
peter thiel has two guys on staff just
sniffing out
an infraction they go hey this hulk
hogan thing
that's it so the story is hulk hogan was
uh either
some hawk hogan was having sex with
someone uh they uh
some third party uh filmed it without
his
consent gawker published the video peter
two goes boom that's
it hey hawk i got the best lawyers i'm
gonna fund you
and if the case wins just give me a
little cut of it peter thiel probably
didn't even take a cut of it
right that's how it could have worked
how could it work exactly and he did
he they did the lawsuit they bankrupt
they basically put
gawker out of business gucker no longer
is is in business
the guy who built that site over the
years you know
it all came falling down because he
pushed it too far he pissed off the
wrong
the wrong billionaire so and by the way
some people think this is bad
whatever i don't care um so what looks
like
not that you don't care that if it is or
is not bad you're saying it's
interesting regardless i'm saying
irrelevant to what we're talking about
as well
whether billionaires should fund
lawsuits and take down media or
not okay whatever so yeah so litigation
finance
is exactly this so basically what he
does is they uh he's a lawyer
he analyzes cases that could be pursued
so
oh you might have a lawsuit here that
you should be pursuing
you for whatever reason maybe you don't
know if you could win you don't realize
it's a
it's a you could potentially sue for for
being wronged
you don't have the money the you know
the corporation can can throw all their
lawyers at this and you you don't want
to go broke trying to
trying to just sue um so you kind of sit
on it so i think it was like 70
plus a potential suits go um
unfiled because of you know one of many
reasons
and so the idea here would be if you see
you can submit to them hey would you
back my
my case and they basically underwrite
the risk of it they look at it they say
oh i think you have a really strong case
or no i think you have a weak case
if you have a strong case they'll say
great we will fund the lawsuit
you get a piece of it if it works if it
doesn't work you lose nothing
and uh and so basically the guy had rate
has now raised or is raising
uh millions and millions of dollars from
family offices and other folks
to fund these cases and so that's what
they're doing now is a thing anyways i
thought it was a cool
listener idea i don't know what you
think of that how much have they raised
how much has he raised i think they
raised something like six million
dollars so far
to um to fund this and he's trying to
get you know basically as a proof of
concept if they could show
that yes we are successfully able to
underwrite these cases meaning we can
correctly select the winners and offer a
payback
great if once we know that we're able to
pay you back 25 30
on your you know annually on your on
your on your financing here
then we can go raise 50 or 100 or 200
million to do more
okay i i've heard of this i didn't
realize this was such a thing
i am so in so there's a company called
burford capital
it's uh founded in 2009 located in
england did you see it
he told me about it he goes this is big
in england there's a multi-billion
dollar company burford blah blah blah
i just googled this while you're talking
i googled
finance legal stuff the first web the
first website
went to pravardi capital the website has
like uh
like a like a monday night football
looking guy wearing a white dude wearing
an ill-fitting suit
right there i'm like opportunity okay
like anytime there's like these like
shitty wix websites with like
basic looking white dudes i'm like
that's interesting second the second
thing that came up was
burford capital i just googled it has a
market cap of 1.8 billion dollars
started in 2009 that's pretty good right
that's pretty this is pretty amazing
exactly so he was like you know i'll
send you the information uh and i told
him i said
look this sounds great uh i don't know
anything about this so i'm probably not
gonna fund it just because
i have two options i can either invest
in things i really understand
or like invest in things i don't
understand i used to do both
but now that this podcast has gotten so
popular now the number of opportunities
that i do understand are so large
they they exceed my investable capital
now i don't have to do [__] i don't
understand anymore
this is a really interesting business
this is but was
so when i you're further along and i
would actually say you're probably a
better investor than i am
when i look at these types of companies
i think like what's the idea that's
important right
i think of i don't have enough time to
go and verify
if this is like a solid market so i look
at who else is
investing right that's probably a lot of
people say oh that's boring you know
are you ever going to take a chance well
probably not to be honest like
i like looking at that but then the
third thing is i look at the person
are they a competent person right um
like so
does this person seem like they're going
to build a huge company off this
uh you know he seemed like a competent
person he seemed like a lawyer who
you know it's i don't think you need to
be the visionary
or like the shark executor i don't think
you need to do anything
for that i think you literally just need
to be um
somebody who's going to do the blocking
and tackling to make this happen i don't
think it requires
genius which is great that's actually a
positive thing for
for this business you don't want to
invest in businesses that require genius
yes but you more likely than not need
some type of charisma
uh in order to be i mean like you either
do need to be a genius so you do need to
be like a peter thiel type of guy
you do need to be maybe like a water
like you or me type of person which we
don't really know how to do that much
but we're charismatic enough to convince
other people to come work at our
companies and convince them to do the
work
yeah um like and then you have like a
few like industry knowledge what
maybe this guy has something you need
attributes as conor mcgregor once said
if you're gonna be you're gonna have
some attributes yeah if you're gonna
beat me
you need some attributes yeah so like
look if you're gonna like succeed
you need that you need some attributes
so what are the attributes gonna be like
something like when you're building a
fighter or building a sports team or
building like a nba player on video
games
and you can like put like do i make this
person like as fast as possible do i
make them as tall as possible do i make
them as strong as possible
you need something there i think that's
the next shirt
you need attributes to beat me yeah so
like what attributes does this guy have
so that's what i'm curious about yeah i
think his
domain knowledge i think that's the
biggest do you agree with me by the way
you need some attributes
you do and what i guess like the only
point i was trying to make is that some
require more attributes than other there
are some where you have to be the
smartest and the fiercest and
fastest and you know like that's there's
some businesses that require that
and there's some where you can be the
tortoise not the hare right and i think
this is one where you could be the
tortoise
you just have to keep going forward and
that's an attribute by the way
determination and just i'm willing to do
it all the time exactly
and uh you know having the steady hand
and being um
being good at actually selecting the
cases right because that's going to just
prove the track record out over time
so i think the domain knowledge matters
all right i wanted to do some other
topics
so i have like three but i don't know
which one i want to do okay i'll give
you
i'll give you some options this is
amazing by the way this is turning out
to be quite good
all right totally unplanned so and by
the way i wrote these down
just while we were talking about the
beginning when the guy canceled all
right so
bitcoin miami i have a few um comments
on what was going on in bitcoin miami i
don't know i heard it was horrible
so we could talk about that we could
talk about um
i have a thing on secondhand ecommerce
if you want to hear that um also
door-to-door sales i have a story there
and the last one is a framework about
the next apple the next google the next
facebook so so tell me they're all great
give me which one you want to do uh
the second one and then the fourth one
okay the second one i think
was uh the secondhand ecommerce thing
yeah all right so let's do that so um
so as you know i've been dabbling in
e-commerce and
you know building up built a brand and
then have gotten built a
community called club ltv that has like
i don't know 100 store owners
each doing somewhere between 1 million a
year and 100 million a year in sales
and so in that i've started to learn
some of the problems the pain points of
e-commerce
one of the interesting things that i
didn't know about that you might know
about right because you've used poshmark
i think
when i was at your house you told me
guess what me and sarah did this weekend
we sold like
97 worth of old clothes on poshmark
and i was like dude what's happening
this is your hobby and you're like yeah
i love this [__]
um i didn't realize how big this
second-hand market for
for e-commerce e-commerce's dude it's
crazy
so let me tell you poshmark uh going
public multi-billion dollar evaluation
is a public party yeah
what what is it uh i don't know we'll
look it up but yeah
it's a public okay there's thread up
spoken hustle count
raised 250 million dollars either going
public or went public already
uh there's grail i discovered grail in
2011 i didn't have any money it was
launched uh
first marks 3.6 billion great there's
grail
i i dm'd this guy because or i messaged
him on reddit years ago because i was on
the day he launched it i was going to
the website i didn't invest in it i
think
it still could be great it's basically
poshmark for hip dudes
what else is there i mean there's like
eight others yeah
let me tell you what i think is
interesting here we
for our store for our our d2c brand we
have
a large amount of people who buy new
and they they're willing to spend more
buying new because they know
there's this has secondary value they
know they could sell it
three months from now six months from
now either new or used and recoup
a good amount of the money so uh certain
certain categories you can do that
better than others
so anyways the uh but but managing this
thing
is is really awful so the way that
people do it today
is sometimes they list on poshmark or
the real real
or um like uh i forgot the other one
makari
mercari's huge um they go they go list
on those exchanges
but a big part of it is they have
facebook groups for every brand so every
brand will have
any brand with with a cult following
will have a secondary market
facebook group called buy sell trade bst
and we b st bst so you can look up any
brand name on facebook go type in the
brand name and like i don't know
your favorite boots or leather jackets
you liked or whatever just type in that
bst
so what you'll see is that there are
these these private groups on facebook
communities
for buying selling and trading what you
already have what you do is you take a
photo of your your closet or your item
you lay it down on the floor
you take a photo of it and you just
write you know like there's all these
acronyms like if you go in there
it's another language it's like mwt that
means new with tag okay great
uh or like you know iso in search of
this product
and so they have their own little lingo
it's this insider community and you post
the item you just say here's what i have
here's what it's for
i have no pets in the house no smokers
and then somebody in the comments will
just say
uh they'll just type in a number it's
like an uh a little auction that would
be like 40
and then you just say done send me your
what's your email i'll send you the
paypal invoice
so there's this like it's like this kind
of like stitched together experience
where then you have to send them the
paypal invoice they have to pay it
um then you have to like find their get
their mailing address you have to ship
it
and then dude i just googled bst i just
found one paintball bst
20k members right and that's what
they'll have they'll have
tens of thousands of members often and
they're very active
and for the brand for the brand
themselves this becomes kind of a
headache
if it's good but it's bad why is it bad
so the first thing is
a bunch of people will buy your product
just to flip it right so they'll go and
they'll sell it for more so
we have a product we have one one of our
products
uh it sells for 65 and then immediately
so it sells out the first minute we
release it
and then it immediately starts selling
for 10 times more so 500 or 600 dollars
on mercari or the second-hand websites
what's the uh what what's that
mercari one m-e-r-c-a-r-i
you've probably seen their billboards
before um they're very good
that's cool so um so anyways so so some
one one part pain point is is these
flippers but that's okay
uh the other part is like you don't
benefit from the secondhand market
directly like you don't get any cut of
those sales that are happening
but uh you do sometimes have customer
service problems because people complain
oh you know i bought this thing from the
official buy sell trade group and
they scammed me or they didn't send it
or they sent the wrong item and you're
like dude this is not my problem like
this is that's not even us that's like
craigslist so like
so you can't complain to us about what's
going on on craigslist so this company
we found um has a very interesting take
on this so i'm trying to invest in this
it's called tread how did you find this
how do you find all this crap
guess who i can
can i how do i share him you need a
you want to give a love letter to ben i
think you fell in love with ben on this
trip
i did um tread is uh tread.com
so sean has this guy who he pays a great
salary to
and his name's ben and i hung out with
ben for the first time
and what ben i admire him so much ben is
and i say this with love
pretty nerdy a nerdy guy and not like
in terms of like looks or acts but like
just like his interests like he just
loves like
gadgets he loves um new stuff and i
started talking about him
and he just brought or talking to him
and he just told me he just browses the
web to find the latest and greatest
stuff
and he'll use it and then he'll dm or
email or message the person who starts
the thing and just say
this is neat here's tips that i would do
to make it better or here's been my
experience using your thing and that's
all he says
and in doing that he sees everything and
knows everyone and i think it's so
fascinating
right he's just uh he's just helpful
okay it's not it's not trend treat is
the name of it treat.kelly i'll send it
to you t-r-e-e-t
dot co um okay so check that out so what
they do
is they have this idea of circular
commerce
meaning you make an item you sell it
and then that person instead of it just
going to waste um they can resell it to
the next person and they can resell it
to the next person it's sort of a
circular
uh commerce model so what do they do say
the url again
t-r-e-e-t treat dot co so what they do
is they give your shopify store
a page or a tab that just creates the
second-hand market
right there in your store so somebody
who wants to buy
a used item can just go buy it
secondhand whip from within your store
um you don't have to do the whole paypal
invoicing facebook group
you know questionable integrity type of
thing anymore uh customers can just list
their stuff here
it can be bought from from your store
which has more trust
than just a random group and the
transaction is processed
you know online using normal credit card
processing and stuff on this
and the brand gets a percent cut you can
set your percent cut
of what you'll take out for hosting the
second-hand market so it's an
additional new revenue stream for a ddc
brand
i think this is really really smart this
does two things
a it legitimizes the sort of secondary
circular nature of it and a lot of
people like that that it's not being
that's like a less wasteful
version of consumerism the second thing
is that
it takes resale and it makes it a part
of your business model as the brand
so for consumers it helps because it's
higher trust
you know the technology is all built you
don't have to do this manually through
facebook groups
and for the brand here's an extra x
percent of revenue that you're going to
make every month because now you
participate
in the resale market that's crazy um i i
don't know if this is a good idea
um how would you feel
as a business i mean you you do i'm
gonna use this because
i want this for our business
do you think a lot of people feel the
same way i don't know we'll see
you know what my gut says super early
make more [__] like why are you selling
out
don't sell out like is you selling out
that sounds like a you problem not a you
need a plug-in problem well it's not
just
not just for selling out right some
people just can't afford the full priced
item
like i don't know you bought those
dumbbells in your in your garage
second hand off facebook marketplace or
whatever right like if you can get the
good
the item in good condition for half the
price
uh for a lot that opens up your buyer
pool into a different segment that can't
maybe always afford the full price item
and you don't have to do heavy
discounting as a brand okay so i'm just
googling as you're talking because we
didn't have time to research but uh
so patagonia's ceo has this great thing
where he goes i actually don't want you
to uh
buy more stuff buy one thing from us and
if you if it rips
if it rips we'll fix it and um it should
just last so like only buy one thing
so i just googled patagonia pre-owned
they have a url that's dedicated to it
called onewhere.patagonia.com
and i'm pretty sure they have their
entire yeah they have an entire way
to buy and sell uh their own their own
gear kind of cool actually it is
actually cool you know who would buy
use patagonia stuff me me
i buy used clothing all the time
whenever i buy red wing boots i always
buy amused
i actually changed my opinion very
quickly i think this is cool
all right i'm glad patagonia got you
across the line okay i have another
uh topic for you do you want to do
another one or yeah keep going wrap it
up
no keep going this is good okay let's do
one more no no you
you had four things where you were at
40. which one you want to do so your
remaining options open the door
door-to-door okay so this is a little
bit longer patagonia's pre-owned website
by the way it's [__] sick
90 jeans for 38 bucks on board
but could treat be a big business uh as
a shopify plug-in
am i being a hater just because it's a
simple shopify plug-in well i don't even
it's not i don't even think it is a
shopify plug-in but
i know what you mean uh yeah i think
it's i think it's the wrong way to think
about it because
if you look at how big the centralized
marketplaces are mercari
poshmark those are three or four billion
this is that same thing but just
decentralized instead of one website
where you go to find all the brands
every brand
has your little marketplace embedded
into it
so i think it's a smart strategy where
you you give the brand the marketplace
instead of trying to get the customer to
come to your app
this is [__] awesome some more here's
some more
so door-to-door sales so this thing has
been happening recently and i know you
love the mormons so i think you'll
you'll dig this love the mormons i love
the mormons so
i have met in the la or i've heard these
stories in the last few days
i'll give you two of door-to-door sales
i have never done
door-to-door sales but i'm almost
jealous that i haven't now so i'll give
you two
words two examples do you know who brian
johnson is
janae might might not be might be hard
to place yeah
so i know two different brian johnsons
one sells books online and the other
started braintree
braintree is the guy i'm talking about
okay that's that's pretty good you know
you get you get 200 points
uh for your house there all right so so
brian johnson i was listening to his
interview he went on um
lex friedman's podcast i was listening
to it does he still work
uh yeah so so his story is insane so he
basically
creates braintree which is like a
payments uh it's basically
a online payments company stripe before
strike it was straight before stripe it
didn't become stripe
but it sold for about 800 800 million
dollars i believe to paypal
and he owned most all of it uh yeah
exactly he owned a huge chunk of it he
also i think they bought venmo along the
way uh
so so he had this strategy early on
which was like
we go to the merchants we get the
merchants to use this because we're so
easy to use online
and then we'll build a consumer uh like
side of the we'll buy
the most hit consumer app and that was
venmo and that would be a valuable
company
and anyway so he builds his company for
800 million dollars he sells it
and he decides what he wanted was he
wanted to have a huge nest egg
to just reinvest into a world-changing
idea
so he's like how do i get as much
financial capital as possible in the
next few years
so that i can self-fund and work on
one of the most like gnarly you know
like few life
world-changing problems so the thing
he's working on and by the way
he thought that braintree wasn't gonna
be i mean that's like pretty
and lex even brings this up he's like
you know online payments actually does
help the world he's like yeah
that's true but i knew that if i didn't
do online payment somebody else would i
wanted to work on
something that if i didn't do it i don't
know if anyone else would
and so the thing he's working on is that
same thing that um that elon is working
on
uh neural link so his is called kernel
kernel it's a it's a brain interface so
so what that means is you put this like
helmet on it looks like a bicycle helmet
and it's basically reading your brain
waves while you're sitting there
and so you know what does that mean
first it can analyze your brain while
you're just doing things so that's
interesting you can get more insight
about yourself
um and there here's what his company's
trying to do is basically spit the data
out
so that all he's trying to do is be able
to read brain data
then any developer can take that those
that data and those learnings
and actually build any application to
improve your life off of it um so that's
what they're trying to build with
colonel
so and by the way he took i think 60
million dollars after he sold braintree
and he funded the first 60 million into
colonel himself because
yeah reading about that right now he put
uh so they've raised um
53 from outside 54 from his own money
yeah 5450 for a million of his own money
exactly and so i think you know most
investors didn't want to touch it
because it's like dude this is just
going to be a money pit
uh you know it's the hardest technology
requires the most expensive engineers
we're not there yet it's going to take
10 years
and he's like yeah don't worry that's
why i that's why i have this nest egg
uh to to fund this thing myself how much
did he make when he sold
um braintree you think i don't know i
don't know the exact number
um but anyways this doesn't even matter
this is just set up those that's the guy
cool guy yeah i would have featured him
maybe as billy of the week and maybe
we'll do a little bit of a deeper job
hey dan let's get this guy on the
podcast this guy's cool
yeah we'll get brian on the part i
thought was pretty remarkable
is his door-to-door sales part okay so
what happened so before he starts
braintree
he um i think he had done a startup and
it was fail it either had failed or it
was
failing and what he did was uh i hope i
don't butcher this story i'm just trying
to remember this
off top my head uh because we didn't
have time to prep today so
what he did was he needed some money so
he he's like okay how do i get money
fast i have my startups failing or i'd
already failed
uh he's like okay i need like a sales
job so he goes and he gets a sales job
with a
um some kind of like financial product
company i think it was like
either like uh credit cards or something
like that for for for businesses
and so he's like he's basically a sales
rep
and he's like okay how do i um
how do i become like the best sales rep
for this and so it became a door-to-door
sales challenge
and so he was going door to door to each
merchant and he was selling them on the
benefits of this product and
and he would then get a commission off
of like kind of the whatever the value
of that customer was over the the next
period of time
and um and so i oh my god i'm going to
butcher this because i can't remember
the hack he used but he had a
he had a very clever technique he was
using when he was going door to door
would that enabled him to become the top
salesman in north america
and so i'm gonna go right in brian did
yeah so he became the number one sales
person
he basically goes door-to-door and he
figures out how to sell this product
and what he said was like door-to-door
sales
is like just this um
like really formative formative
experience for anybody
because you have to have like an
incredible amount of determination
you're going to get rejected all the
time and you need to learn how to like
get your foot in the door how to get
somebody's attention how to get them
interested and how to close them
in order to sell any product
door-to-door and then i
so so i heard the story from brian
johnson and he talked about how
important that experience was to him
next day i go meet my uncle
i have an uncle who i've talked about on
the pod before because i consider him to
be
the happiest man on earth uh he's a real
estate uncle
a real estate uncle his name's uncle
vinnie
literally people uh just coined his name
smiley
uh so they just stopped calling him
vinnie people just call him smiley
because he's just so smiley like
his company they got him a trophy
because he's the number one sales person
and on the trophy they didn't put his
name they just wrote
smiley and that became kind of like the
nickname that stuck and
they didn't even ask his permission they
just knew this is the right name for
this guy
so he's incredibly happy but he's also
been incredibly successful and i would
say
i don't think he's in all of my my aunts
my uncles
in terms of iq just raw intelligence
i don't know he's probably either 50
percentile
maybe even less maybe maybe half maybe
half him
sorry vinny no and i mean this with love
because uh whatever the point i'm making
is
good thing they didn't call him dopey
smells a lot better he's
he's the most successful of anyone in
our family
but it's not because he had more raw
horsepower in the brain that's not the
reason that that he
was able to do it and uh so i was
telling my trainer about him
and he goes i'd love to meet him and i
go what he goes
yeah does he where does he live i go he
lives in danville actually lives you
know not far away from here you know 30
minute drive
he goes could we just go meet him i was
like yeah so i texted my uncle i said
hey
i was telling my trainer about you and
he just he wants to meet you
and he goes he was like sure come on bye
no problem
yes like can't wait to see you uh and i
was like i was like
who doesn't and i was like i noted to
myself he didn't even ask why what's the
context you want something from me
he's just like yes uh you wanna you
wanna meet me yes
and i also thought to myself what what a
goal by the way
to be the type of person that people
wanna make a pilgrimage out you know to
go drive an hour to go
see um just just because of a
description of
the way you are i thought that's kind of
amazing because he doesn't want anything
from him he's not trying to get a
business deal or
get a customer out of him he just heard
how his personality is and i was like i
gotta meet this guy
so we go we drive out there and we sit
down
and uh you know he's already on level 10
excitement and
we're having a great time and i started
asking him i said you know
when did you become you where did you
become this way you weren't born this
way
so how did you become this way and he
was telling me the long story and he
talked about
this door-to-door sales job he goes i
came from india
and i'm a student at university he goes
uh george washington university i think
he goes i needed a summer job i needed
he's like i came here i only had enough
tuition the government paid for my
tuition for the first year
i had no idea how i was gonna pay for
the second year but like
i have one summer to bridge that gap
like how the heck am i gonna make next
fall's tuition
so he looked for a job and his roommate
was like hey i worked for this company
that called southwestern i don't know if
you ever heard of this company you're
gonna love it
but basically this company called
southwestern and what they do is they
sell books
so they sell books door-to-door they
have this fleet of college students
that will go out and they'll sell these
books like encyclopedias
um dictionaries bibles um
um you know any textbooks of any kind
and southwestern advantage
is what it's called and so and they've
they've since grown like crazy they
acquired all
now it's like 20 something companies and
it's like a multi-billion dollar company
crazy story about the founder i'm going
to have him as the billy of the week
as a special profile but i want to tell
this door-to-door sales story so he goes
okay great so what do i do he's like you
know i can barely speak english because
i'm just here from india but okay i
gotta go do door-to-door sales how do i
do that
he's like they gave this this training
where
um you they give us seven books like you
know how to win friends and influence
people
you know uh you know like these seven
kind of classic self-help books tony
robbins and
whatever he's like read these seven
books and then come to this training
seminar he goes i go to this thing it's
an auditorium
and it's me and like you know the 50
other college students and there's this
stage and there's just a door frame on
the stage and
you'd have to get up and you'd have to
knock on the door and then they would
have an act you know like the
person from the company on the other
side an actor who is like i'm mrs
johnson
and you you open the door mrs johnson
and she would simulate like slamming the
door on your face and being like
like stop bothering us right or somebody
who's like lukewarm or somebody who's
interested and they would teach you how
to sell door-to-door
and he talked he talked to me he's like
i used to they used to dr
uh but my job basically every day in the
summer and i'm in the you know the heat
of summer
i would my roommate would drive me to
some neighborhood any neighborhood i
would just pick a different one every
day
and at 9am he would drop me off i didn't
own a car so i needed him to pick me up
at the end of the day so he's like 9am
he'd drop me off in a neighborhood and
9pm he'd come pick me up
at the end of the day and he's like i
would go door to door and i'd
knock and they would teach you the
skills of selling door-to-door so do you
know i don't know if you have you ever
heard this i was fascinated by
how you act what is the actual method of
selling when you're door-to-door have
you ever heard this
um no well so you typically say hey
i was just talking to a bunch of your
neighbors and they thought this was
interesting and so here i am talking to
you
that that's definitely part of it but he
broke it down step he's like there's a
scientist that they taught us at this
training he goes
first you ring the doorbell you knock on
the door and you don't look into the
door
because when you look at the door it's a
little bit intimidating um and they see
your face they recognize that they don't
know you
um he's like you want to look slightly
you know off 45 degree angle
away so that they're gonna like when
they look through the peephole they're
gonna be like okay i don't know who this
guy is but it doesn't look too
threatening
and then what are they trying to get you
to do like to step your foot into the
door eventually
basically so you they open the door and
you you explain the pitch that you just
said which is
you know hi my name is my name is vinnie
and um
i'm a student here at george washington
nearby um
and i actually have been uh you know
i've been talking to your neighbors
uh we what we do is we sell uh you know
we sell tech or whatever it is he's
basically saying
i was talking to your neighbors and i
wanted to stop by your place i'm a
student nearby
right so you you become a local you're
not a stranger
you're a friend right so you you you
imagine you want to put like a time
stamp like
there's only going to be i'm i actually
i have to go in a second yeah exactly
i don't have a bunch of time but i would
love to just you know chat with you
whatever right and he goes
he goes uh a lot of people what they
would try to do
is the door sample meaning they would
tell them i'm here to sell you a
textbook
check out this book is this something
you're interested in and then you know
the learning is nobody ever buys a book
at the door and i thought that's
actually like a very applicable thing
for almost every kind of sale
is you're because you're afraid of
getting rejected you rush
you rush to try to just sample it you
know
give them give them the value so you
don't annoy them but the reality is that
that's not how
a product like this would ever be bought
nobody's ever going to buy this at the
door itself
so he goes you want to get into the home
the whole objective of the door is to
get into the home
and it reminded me of your writing style
where you go i was about to say this
this is why i always say longer is
better i want them to fall down my
slippery slope
and explain the slippery slope it's like
the first line the goal of the first
right look there's only one goal of a
headline
of a sales page and that's to get you to
read the sub headline
the only goal the sub headline is to get
you read the first sentence and the only
goal the first sentence is to get you
read the second sentence i'm going to
keep on doing that until you fall down
the slippery slope
and not only a lot of people say i want
to make this very easy to read
so do i i want to make it easy to read
as well but i'm going to tell you a
story and i'm not going to rush it and i
want you to fall
slowly fall down the slippery slope and
i want to make it kind of hard for you
because the more pot committed you are
the more likely you are to buy
exactly exactly so this is the same
exact thing so he wanted to get into the
home so he goes
you asked to come in and um and you you
don't
you don't look them in the face you sort
of lead with your arm and your face you
sort of like
point where you're trying to go like
into their living room right behind them
so you say
you know would you mind if i come in for
a moment and you you sort of point your
way into the door
and uh if you're once you're in the door
now your close rate has gone from like
0.01
to like 30 or 40 percent just because
you're there you're sitting and you're
sitting down
so you're not like standing anymore it's
not by the way this is why on all my
landing pages i always ask for email
first because once you give me your
email you're just a little bit more
bought in you're in the door exactly
and you know they might offer you a
water or a drink you say yes you don't
say no
now you're both sitting there you have
your water and you start to explain to
them and now you need to put it in the
context of their problem so you look
around the house oh i see you have
children
how old are they oh i got a boy and girl
myself uh yeah
you know blah blah blah this this age is
the craziest blah blah blah
what are your kids doing for what do you
do for a kind of after school education
for your children and that's how you're
leading into the encyclopedia sale
that's how you're leading into the
textbook sale is you need to frame your
your product as a solution to their
problem right so this is all like
you know this is common sense but i just
loved it yeah common dog
uh i think that like a lot of people
don't know this i think
you want you so i learned it so i read
how to win friends and
influence people by the way all those
old like uh fuzzy books like how to win
friends and
people influence people they can grow
rich it sounds silly
i endorse all of them fully that [__]
totally helps you tony robbins totally
helps you i'm i'm
entirely on board with that right the
founder of panda express makes all of
his employees go through a tony robbins
and how to
influence people uh seminar totally on
board with it
um it's that i learned how to do this
when i was selling hot dogs and then you
know what else i did like every other 18
year old
i i use it to meet girls right and it
totally worked and i mastered that
well i wasn't like that good but like
for i i stepped up my game from
uh significantly when i learned how to
do all this right right exactly and so
he told me a couple things out of that
he goes um
he's like here i am i'm a hindu selling
bibles to to bear i mean indian hindus
selling bibles to americans
and he's like that experience that whole
summer he's like
you know i it changed me he's like
first i'm working hard i'm there at 9 am
i'm walking around
carrying loads and loads of books and
i'm walking door to door and
i'm getting mostly rejected uh but then
you know
if i get even an inch she's like i used
to schedule a same-day follow-up he's
like so
oh now's not a good time you know would
it be better this evening when your
husband's home like maybe
5 p.m great i'll be back because he's
like i'm just walking around the
neighborhood anyways i'll walk right
back to this
he's like so i was scheduling same-day
follow-ups to keep the
keep the ladies like by the second time
they met me now i'm not a stranger he's
like nothing has changed they don't know
anything more about me but it's just the
second time they've seen me
and um and so there was all these little
things i thought were really applicable
to sales
but also i started thinking about these
formative experiences the really hard
experiences
uh like what's a hard business
experience and i think this is actually
pretty underrated so he said
learn to work hard i learned how to sell
i learned how to build rapport and talk
to people
and he's like i wasn't doing it to
manipulate anybody he's like i just
genuinely
would life was a lot more fun if i got
to know the person
rather than you know having a standoff
relationship and then them being angry
that i'm bothering them that day
and it got to the point where one woman
would be like are you walking around
carrying all these books he's like well
yeah you know i have to uh and she's
like here's the keys to my car here's my
van
drive my van around the neighborhood
instead so she gave him this car
to actually do the sale so it went from
most people slam the door on a door to a
salesman she gave him his her car
to make it easier for him to go do what
he was doing he still keeps in touch
with her 36 years later or something
like that 40 years later
he's like yeah you know she just sent me
this cake and like mrs whatever her name
was
he's like we're still good friends
actually because and we met because i
sold her you know a bible back in the
day
and um so i thought this was interesting
so i think there's something to this
and from two levels what are the
opportunities here i thought hey
um who's doing door-to-door sales now
are there still companies that
primarily sell door-to-door i'm going to
research them and find something yeah
i mean like some really they're probably
the most famous one is cutco you know
cutco
no what is that um wow you've never
heard of cutco so they make knives in
kitchenware
their knives are actually pretty good
but their whole business model
is uh door to door and um like
i've got friends that have done it it's
reputable in the sense that it's a good
product
right some people think it's scammy but
because they're like direct sales and
multi-level marketing but it's legit
right and so i'm interested in these
direct sales companies
i'm also interested in hiring people who
are successful door-to-door sales people
in fact there was a guy on the podcast
early on
who did this for solar he's like my
first job was door-to-door sales i was
selling solar
like hey you know have you ever thought
about doing solar it lowers your bill
and blah blah blah
we can help you out it's good for the
environment and he's like dude it was
hard as [__] but i got good at it i
became the top sales person
and i kind of feel like i can i will
never go wrong if i hire the top
salesperson from any door-to-door sales
company it's like
works hard knows how to sell um like
what else do you need when you're when
you're trying to hire somebody well you
want to hear something funny you know
who jordan belford is
yeah the wolf of wall street oh we
talked about it this weekend i think you
haven't read his book you should
so jordan belford was the wolf of wall
street he made hundreds of millions of
dollars selling penny stocks to rich
people and he was a great sales person
he created this thing called straight
line persuasion
he started by selling fish
and steaks door-to-door
[Laughter]
that's how his entire thing started was
door-to-door yeah it's a great book but
it was all it's all door-to-door sales
yeah so i don't really have i don't
really know what the point of this is
it's more like
i loved hearing these stories i
i'm sort of jealous i never had this
experience because i think i would be
better at what i do
if i did um and i want to go further i
want to research these companies and i
want to start hiring people
out of this pool of talent i think it is
an underrated pool of talent
just like we talked about you know sort
of mormons who go on the mission
and they have to sell sort of the
hardest thing sell a religion to
somebody who never asked you to come
sell it to them
and they have to do that for two years
that does create a certain
sales ethic and work ethic in a person
and uh we've seen that take place that's
why almost all the direct sales
companies all the uh
the successful direct sales companies
are all based out of utah
um because that's where the talent is
that knows how to do this sort of thing
i think for i would say for not
preparing this episode turned out to be
pretty amazing and i would say
even amongst all episodes this has been
one of my favorite dan
do you agree that this has been fire
this has been great guys
door-to-door sales was awesome what
about the other stuff
the other stuff was good too you guys
just finished with a big bang
yeah um i think this ended up being a
winner um
so that's the episode i think right
we're gonna wrap up there let's rap
um tomorrow or wednesday i want to talk
about co-working spaces i think we have
to have a my first million co-working
business yeah you like that idea i do
that was another bad idea and i think
it's wonderful so i tweeted out
who i could talk to i got a bunch of
interesting stuff um
we're going to talk about that next week
wednesday
[Music]
travel never looking back